- I'LL SHOW WOODY.
HOW HARD COULD IT BE
TO FIND A CUTE ANIMAL?
LET'S SEE.
UGLY, FAT, TOO ETHNIC.
BINGO.
EXCUSE ME, FOLKS.
[clatter]
OFFICIAL PARK BUSINESS.
COME HERE, YOU RASCAL.
- OH!
- EXCUSE ME, EXCUSE ME.
SORRY, SORRY.
- OH! GET AWAY FROM ME!
- SORRY. ALMOST GOT IT.
- [grunts]
- GOT IT. LUCKILY, IT GOT
CAUGHT IN YOUR PANTIES.
YOU FOLKS HAVE A NICE DAY.
WOODY IS GOING TO LOVE YOU.
- THIS IS THE MOST ADORABLE
ANIMAL EVER.
AW, LOOK AT YOU.
AAH!
- OH, MY GOD,
YOU ARE CUTE!
WHICH IS CUTER?
I DON'T KNOW.
THE TOURISTS
LOVED THE SQUIRREL.
THE HIKER, GOD REST HER SOUL,
LOVED THE RABBIT.
IF ONLY I COULD HAVE BOTH.
BUT HOW?
[inspirational music]
♪
THAT'S IT!
YOU GUYS JUST NEED TO
[bleep] EACH OTHER.
[playing classical music]
♪
OKAY, ENOUGH FOREPLAY.
[liquid sloshing]
YES! WORK IT!
GET IN BALLS DEEP!
POUND IT!
PUMP IT!
[breezy music]
ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY,
LISTEN UP.
I HAVE AN IMPORTANT
ANNOUNCEMENT.
THIS BOX I HOLD BEFORE YOU
CONTAINS THE CUTEST ANIMAL
ON THE PLANET.
IT'S HALF SQUIRREL,
HALF RABBIT.
I CALL IT THE SQUABBIT.
- OH, MY GOD, OH, MY GOD,
OH, MY GOD!
SO CUTE, I CAN'T TAKE
MY EYES OFF HIM.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN
A CUTER ANIMAL?
LOOK AT THAT.
OH, I JUST WANT TO
CUDDLE HIM.
- IT'S NOT THAT CUTE.
IT'S GOT THOSE
TAYLOR SWIFT TEETH.